covert 19 combined with the usual winter
pressures is putting immense pressure on
our hospitals we have seen the number of
coronavirus cases
rising in the past couple of weeks and
that is now feeding through
to the number of people in hospital as
of yesterday there were 20
426 people in hospital in england with
covert 19
and that means they're now more people
in hospital with coronavirus than at any
one point during the first wave back in
april
the number of patients in hospital
peaked at just under 19
000. it dropped off quite substantially
over the summer but it's been rising
again
and that has now passed 20 000. doctors
and paramedics say
that is putting a huge strain on the nhs
but we know
that winter is always a tricky time for
the health service so this
is this just standard winter pressures
or are things worse because of the
coronavirus
this graph shows us the number of
emergency admissions hospitals in
england dating from june 2015 to
november
this year which is the most recent data
that we have and this shows us that
although
there are some fluctuations with numbers
typically rising around the winter
months
the number of emergency admissions is
not higher than its similar points in
the last few years however
this doesn't tell us how long patients
are in hospital for it's worth
remembering
that we don't have december's figure yet
and because there's always a lag of a
couple of weeks from getting infected
to potentially going into hospital the
rise in cases we have seen in the last
fortnight
could push that level up so it's not a
complete picture yet
we've been hearing though from doctors
and nurses who say hospitals are under
real pressure and one of the reasons for
this may be
staffing there are around 84 000 vacant
staff positions in the nhs
38 000 of which are in nursing posts
in fact one in 10 nursing posts in the
nhs
are currently unfilled and that's partly
explained
why even though admissions are not yet
exceeding the levels we've seen in
previous years
on the ground things are still very
stretched